face aux dangers de la grippe aviaire le
président de la république a demandé
aujourd'hui l'application du principe de
précaution afin que chaque français
soient protégés ou puissent être soignés
en cas d'apparition de la maladie en
fait à un dispositif complet a déjà été
prévu et tout est en place en cas de
pandémie
mais pour le moment pas de panique il
n'y a aucune preuve de la transmission
du virus de l'animal à l'homme jean-paul
geai roi jean pierre ryckmans branle bas
de combat à bruxelles tous les experts
sanitaires ont examiné aujourd'hui les
risques de contamination des poux les
européens par la grippe aviaire le
danger pour les cheptels viendrait de
russie ou d'asie derrière ce souci des
volatiles une angoisse majeur la
mutation du virus qui le rendrait
transmissible d'homme à homme
transmissibles est dévastateur si vous
voulez la fourchette an du nombre de
morts par une pandémie si elle devait se
déclarer va de 1 à 100 c'est à dire que
certains disent ça fera 2 millions de
morts dans le monde en quelques mois et
d'autres ont même dit on ira 200 voire
300 millions de morts dans le monde
estimations pour la france entre 90 et
200 mille morts tous les problèmes
sanitaires révélées par la crise
canicule risque donc de se poser à
nouveau et une échelle bien plus large à
l'institut de veille sanitaire
l'épidémiologiste daniel lévy bruhl doit
tout envisager la pression sur les
hôpitaux entre autres serait encore bien
pire que pendant la canicule en 2003
vous voyez que par exemple au pic de
l'épidémie au pic de la pandémie
ici ce sont des milliers de cas eh bien
il pourrait y avoir dans la première
vague si on fait l'hypothèse qu'elle est
moins importante que la deuxième environ
80000 personnes hospitalisées en une
semaine voir dans le scénario un petit
peu plus pessimistes cent soixante mille
personnes en plus bien entendu de la
charge hospitalière habituel il faudra
accueillir mais aussi soigner le virus
mutant sur la très contagieux aucun
vaccin ne sera disponible avant
plusieurs mois
un seul médicament le tamiflu sera
réellement efficace en traitement comme
prévention
depuis quelques mois les grands pays se
précipitent pour acheter des millions de
doses la france a passé la plus grosse
commande mondial 13 millions de
traitements pour faire face le
laboratoire roche a entrepris d'élargir
sa capacité de production
mais
aussi de proposer le médicament sous sa
forme brute aussi dans des fûts comme
cela c'est vraiment la première fois
qu'on fait ça permet d'abaisser les
coûts dans chaque fût il ya 7000
personnes pendant quatre à cinq jours il
suffit de dissoudre le produit dans
l'eau et le distribuer en petites
bouteilles le livre on au gouvernement
nous leur expliquons comment mettre ça
en place président en cas de pandémie
le médicament ne sera pas le seul
problème
il faudra aussi équipé en gore et en
masques de protection les personnels
soignants mais aussi toutes les
professions jugé indispensable au
fonctionnement du pays
parce qu'au plus fort de l'épidémie
c'est toute l'activité économique qui
pourrait s'arrêter
la grippe aviaire si elle survient sera
un véritable séisme social une pandémie
ça veut dire une désorganisation de la
vie quotidienne à des degrés plus ou
moins importants
ça veut dire probablement des mesures
qui vont devoir être prises qui seront
des mesures qui pourront être
attentatoire à la liberté individuelle
on ne pourra plus faire ce qu'on veut on
sera obligé de respecter certaines
contraintes fortes des années de les
enfants pourront peut-être plus aller à
l'école qu'on décidera de fermer les
écoles
d'ores et déjà on peut trouver sur le
site internet du ministère de la santé
des vidéos expliquant les conduites à
tenir face à une éventuelle pandémie
le risque est mondiale et le défi pour
les gouvernements est partout le même
alerté sans paniquer sur une épidémie
qui reste virtuel